here is a a perfectly legal 20 dollar
banknotes from the United States of
America and the gamble is you extend
your fingers like this in a v-shape and
you try to catch it when I drop the
banknote like this yeah in mid-flight
and if you can catch it when I drop it
you'll get the banknote and if you don't
you don't get the back shot I'm gonna
drop it at some unannounced time okay
you shouldn't guess one more time oh no
most people at least the vast majority
people can't get it and that's because
there is something called the reaction
time in most humans in other words you
see something or you feel something and
then it's processing the brain and brain
sends back a command to the body saying
do something and that's the reaction
time and that reaction time in most
people is of the order of 0.2 seconds it
varies from person person but
approximate 0.2 seconds we learn in high
school and elsewhere that when you
dropped any object you know this this or
this this stuff falls in freefall over a
distance which is equal to 1/2 GT
squared where T is the time of the fall
and G is the gravitational acceleration
G is about 10 meters per second per
second
it's 9.8 but that's close enough T
reaction time that we have to catch this
is 0.2 so if you square that that's 0.04
have that is 0.02 times 10 that is equal
to 0.2 that's in meters that is equal to
20 centimeters approximately so in the
human reaction time in the average
reaction time this object falls site 20
centimeters this is Aconitum Arruda 15.5
centimeters so it's significantly but
not by much shorter than 20 centimeters
so it falls more than the its own neck
so when you start from even from the
bottom you can't catch it because by the
time the signal is sent to the brain
and brain sends back the signal to do
something it's already fallen more than
its body length so it is quite amazing
that the United States of America made a
banknote which is slightly shorter than
20 centimeters which matches exactly 0.2
seconds human reaction time this isn't
going to work on everyone humans the
different humans are different for
example I know that though though my
esteemed assistant and in fact the
cameraman the man behind me a number
file couldn't catch it in previous
experiments actually when we do it
honestly he sometimes camp because his
reaction times actually pretty good with
my right hand with my you do right hand
and also I'm cheating you see if
you wanted to make sure that people have
the minimum chance you ask them to
extend those looking as these two
fingers don't move so fast
those two are probably fastest pair so
try doing it with if you can hold your
card over your right hand and now hit
the take a second okay yeah now Brady
Haran he's really quick
oh well twenty dollars a steak and you
shouldn't be kissing Oh watching before
I know you were catching them before but
no okay yeah okay you have to thank you
but this time each paperclips is the
included band but not between themselves
let's finish with something that is
working progress so far we have been
linking paper clips together and
sometimes we refer to this as addition